hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar role of neutralizing antibodies
in recovery from covid19 infection and
protection following vaccination
i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by diocerine to learn more visit
them at dinosaurin.com
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting any questions you
might have during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain those credits i'd now like to
welcome our speaker dr ishik ratson an
advisor quality r d knowledge forum
pathkind labs at the who laboratory
director
dr ratten welcome you may now begin your
presentation
good morning good afternoon good evening
wherever you are
it was on
on 31st december 2019
that who was informed regarding an
outbreak of pneumonia caused by a novel
coronavirus in gohan
by 10th
january
2020
one full sequence of this rna virus was
available in public domain
by next day
five more sequences were available
this made
making rt pcr for this rna virus
easy
and that was one of the first tests
to be developed
in india
in january 2020 there was only one lab
which could
detect corona virus
but
by september 2020
2234 labs
were accredited and approved for doing
rtpcr by indian council of medical
research
manufacturers
also got
many molecular
physiology
and antigens
tests
approved by various
regulatory authorities
from buhan the report had already
indicated
that
rtpcr was less than perfect as far as
detection
of corona virus was concerned
and new indicated
that if you wanted to have
better
diagnosis then you need to add serology
after nine days or so
miller from boston
so it meant that it was not
the gold standard that you were looking
for
miller from boston
then instituted the policy
that everybody admitted in their
hospital
would have rtpcr and antibodies tested
they found
that in the first nine days
rtpcr was the most sensitive test for
making a diagnosis
but thereafter
antibodies
were better for making the diagnosis
while arctic pcr sensitivity fell
and they reported
that when used as a complementary test
with rtpcr
after the first nine days
periology can function as a reliable
diagnostic
aid indicating recent or prior infection
so the first few days
of infection
rna or antigen detection is the analyte
to test
thereafter it is physiology which could
be useful
today
our focus will be on humoral immunity
and how host responds to an infection
once there is exposure
to the antigen either after infection or
vaccination there is a lag
period thereafter
the titus rise
and after initial rise they would
decline
it's when the titus are declining that
we need a boosted dose
to jack up the immune response
the two antigens which are of prime
importance
are
the five proteins
which is on the surface
and the nuclear capsule protein
which is inside
the
virus
our aim is that
in natural infection
the spike protein will bind
to as2 receptor and enter into the cell
and set up infection
we hope to detect neutralizing
antibodies
which will
neutralize which will bind to the five
protein
and prevent its union
through the ac2 receptors
and therefore thereby
giving protection
it was clear right in the beginning
that
not everybody produces very high types
those who had severe infection and were
admitted into icu
had higher titles of antibodies
but those who had non-critical
infections or mild infection would have
mild response
this might explain
why
many convalescent plasma trials
gave different results if they did not
measure
the neutralizing antibodies and some
even failed
but it is clear
that if the plasma contains
high titles of antibodies
then it will be protective
antibodies
when transfused into
animals
provided protection
and animal models both
in
incident hamster
as well as in african green monkey model
were established
which proved that it was possible to
protect against a reinfection
once antibodies are transfused to them
it was also possible to make human
monoclonal antibodies
by
taking out the b lymphocytes from
persons who have recovered
and then expanding them
it was a cocktail of these b lymphocytes
the lymphocytes produced monoclonal
antibodies
which were
injected into the then president donald
trump
leading to his quick recovery
an experiment was reported that mcmahon
indicating that when purified
antibodies
against
rscov2
were injected into groups of animals
only the and and then they were
subsequently challenged with the virus
only the animals which had got 250
milligrams per kg body weight of
purified antibodies were fully protected
at the time when they were fully
protected
the anti-spike antibodies were 400
nt rbd antibodies were 100
and neutralizing antibodies for more
than 50 percent
so it it emerged that
antibodies to spike protein
are the key to prevent infection
and you will notice
that most of the successful vaccines
have focused on spike protein
to be the antigen of vaccination
the spike protein is
is an amino acid
consists of
1273 amino acids
it has two
broad
portions
one is
s1
s1 subunit which has the receptor
binding domain and within the receptor
binding domain is the receptor binding
motif which binds to the ac2 receptors
then there is
s2 unit subunit
which has the fusion peptide
it was also seen that the spike protein
is actually a trimeric protein
and the trimeric protein
appears to exist the trimers appear to
exist in closed
or open form
when it is open
then they have more affinity for the as2
receptor
after
mapping the neutralizing antibodies
epitopes are mapped on the 5 protein
and it was found
that they seem to be about 19 different
epitopes which can provide
protection and neutralization so it was
not only
the rbd portion but other sites
on the spy protein
which
could when bound to the antibodies would
lead to neutralization
and it was seen that pull protection was
better
mirrored if you look at the trimeric
protein
primeric reactive immunoglobulins
correlated better with starch to
covet protection
as i mentioned that the primary protein
could be in the closed form or in the
open form
when one mutation occurred which opened
up
one of the trimers
that led to
increase
in
in
increasing infection and this mutation
was the first mutation noticed
in
2020
wherein
wherein one of the
wherein the mutation was g
d 6 1 4 g
leading to opening up of one of the arms
and as a consequence the infection
spread
subsequently
mutations in the rbd have been
associated
with
various
immune escape mechanisms and increase in
virulence
so in 2020 the mutation which was
predominant was b
614g
which
appeared in february and by june
was the predominant infection found in
all over the world and this year there
has been the delta variant which is
which has spent all over the world now
along with the spread of the
uh of the
variant there has been also development
of monoclonal antibodies
and
the monoclonal antibodies could
neutralize
a mixture of monoclonal antibodies can
utilize all the variants and have been
found to be effective
they could be used
they are active against all known
variants and efficacy is 85
in reduction
in hospitalization and death
the monoclonal antibodies or the
cocktail of that could be used
both for treatment
if given in the first 72 hours of
infection
or could be used subcutaneously
or prevention of those who are at high
risk and are getting exposed
for psychological tests there are
various types of psychological tests and
all not all psychological tests are the
same
first will depend upon the antigen the
nucleocapsid protein is the most
immunogenic
but it it resides inside the video
the spike protein could be s1 s2 or
could be trimetic or we could have rbt
receptor binding domain
then we could look at
total antibodies or igg or a mixture of
igg and igm
and then we could have type of
assays which could be binding antibodies
and neutralizing antibodies
it's also very important to choose the
right format
the tests are available for
lateral flow
but the lateral flow rapid tests are
normally not very sensitive
and are only
qualitative not quantitative
recently attempts to
quantitate that has also been made by
using fluorescent labels
then you have neutralizing antibodies
which are most mostly
elisa
and you have
binding antibodies which can be
chemilumisens so they are automated and
suitable for high throughput screening
so depending upon the purpose for which
you are doing the investigation you
should choose the right serological test
if it is for epidemiology then
nucleocapsid protein because it is the
most immunogenic would be more suitable
while if you are looking for protection
or a surrogate for protection then spike
protein especially using the trimeric s
protein would be good
the difference between
the two is that since nucleocapsid
protein resides inside the cell
it could normally indicate infection and
would not play a role in protection
on the other hand
binding antibodies can bind to any part
of the spike protein
but
protective antibodies are those which
can protect a person by holding on
to the fight which leads to infection
by neutralizing them it is the
neutralizing antibodies which
indicate the closest you can get to
showing protection
neutralizing antibodies normally are
demonstrated by plaque reduction
neutralization test
wherein
a monolayer of
cells are created
and on which the virus
is layered the sample containing the
virus is cleared if the virus is present
then
virus will cause phytopathogenic effect
which indicates like plaques here and
that would indicate that the virus is
present
neutralization of this plaque formation
would indicate
that the plasma
or the serum contains antibodies which
can prevent infection
the problem is
that for utilizing antibodies you need
by safety level three laboratories
because you're using live virus which is
causing the pandemic and it takes three
to five days before the results are
available
so scientists made pseudo virus since we
were interested only in the spike
protein so the gene
coding for the spike protein was
inserted into harmless virus and then
this could be and a pseudo virus was
created which would provide the same
information
this was created initially
and reported in china
subsequently in italy
and this enabled
labs
with bsl ii facility
to perform the test but it still took
three to five days
since we wanted the results the same day
then cell free virus we genetically
engineered
rbd linked to
what
to a label
with these two receptors
was used in elisa and this would then
indicate whether
utilization is present or not
when tested in singapore as well as in
china it could differentiate between
those who had protection and those who
had no exposure
this was then given emergency approval
by usfda and also by icmr and dcpi in
india
many manufacturers could make this test
and
when tested they had equivalent results
when we tested in 2000 in august 2020
we used one was the nuclear captured
antibodies and the other one was
antibodies against spike protein and we
found that majority of the person tested
had low tighter antibodies
and so they were not suitable for
transfusion
subsequently
in
in march april there was a big outbreak
caused by delta virus and many of our
staff members also got infected in fact
in 2020 11 had got infected
and in 2021
by delta virus
11 and one
12 got infected one person had got
infected and recovered from 2020 but 11
new persons got infected
they were also vaccinated so some of
them had taken one dose and some had
taken two doses and some had not taken
any dose so when we tested them we found
that using
s1 s2
12 have more than 400
arbitrary units per ml but when we
tested with trimeric we found that
trimeric was much more sensitive
and
12 of them had more than 2 000
binding antibody units per ml but many
of them had higher titles
who has now made antibodies standard
antibody test available so that the
binding unit could be converted
arbitrary units could be converted into
binding antibody unit
when we looked at individual responses
against f1 s2 and trimeric antibodies we
found that not everybody
responded by producing high antibodies
and this was especially in
persons who have older age group
those who had vaccines had
medium titer of antibodies
but those who had had
vaccination as well as suffered from
infection
either
in 2020
or
2021 by the delta variant and very high
titles of antibiotics
even one dose and infection
or infection and one dose produce very
high tight
when we added neutralizing antibodies
we find that
trimeric antibodies and utilizing
antibodies would
would go there was consistency
in very high trimeric antibodies and
neutralizing antibodies and so trimeric
antibodies could act as surrogate
markers for neutralization
but those persons as i said
if a person has had infection and then
taken vaccination or vaccination and
then get got infected
they had very high cycles even one dose
was enough
with along with vaccination to produce
high antibodies
this was also reported by tremecker from
new york who found that
if we investigated between persons who
had pre-existing antibodies and then
vaccinated after one dose
those persons produced much higher
titles
than those who had not had antibodies
and that remained after sucking those
also
in fact those who were already
vaccinated or infected and got two
vaccinations had more side effects
than titus
this is then been reported as covet 19
hybrid immunity so natural infection
itself
is gives protection from reinfection
from the same virus
unless a mutant
arises a variant
emerges but
infection followed by vaccination will
provide
much better hybrid ability
even in vaccination initially homologous
vaccinations were insisted upon by all
by all regulatory authorities but
sometimes by mistake or sometimes by
design as you know sputnik vaccination
already has two different human
adenoviruses
while kovi shield which is the vaccine
used in india
was interchanged by mistake by
co-vaccine and they got good results
the same has been reported in europe
with oxford astrazeneca followed by
fighters
or with modern
so heterologous waxy seems to be
giving good results
but muladin reported that not everybody
produces high antibodies and they found
that persons who were
elderly had
both
less
igg antibodies
and neutralizing antibodies
from qatar the reports came
that after the vaccination
there was a decrease
in protection against infection
but protection against severe infection
or death
continued at high level
it was also
shown
that
in transplant patients if a third dose
of the vaccination is given they have
high immune response
from israel it has been reported
that a third dose to those
whose
tigers were falling would give them good
immunity
and protect them
recently an ongoing study has been
reported this is the octave trial which
is observational cohort trials
t cells antibodies and
vaccine applications charge kobe 2
from
from scotland
and this has
has taken
patients who are immunocompromised like
having inflammatory arthritis rheumatoid
arthritis or pseudoticata psoriatic
arthritis
anka associated vasculitis inflammatory
bowel syndrome
hepatic disease and kidney disease solid
cancer
hematological malignancies in and
homophobic stem cell transplant and they
found that all of them
had at least 11 percent less tighter
than
did not produce any tighter and 40
percent of them have low tightest than
healthy persons
anti-spike t-cell response was similar
in immunocompromised patients as well as
healthy patients so indicated that the
increased susceptibility that they have
is because of lack of production of
antibodies
recently
usa cdc has authorized booster
doses for certain age groups and certain
persons with high disk and this has been
also committed both for
for johnson junction as well as for
modena
in the past it was indicated that one
dose would give less protection than two
doses and it was encouraged that we
should complete the doses as soon as
possible
uh effect of vaccination was also felt
in household transmission
from scotland they reported on
one 1.9 million household members which
indicated 92 000 households
with healthcare workers
of these those who
were vaccinated
had less chances their family members
have less chances of infection after the
first and the second dose than those who
were not vaccinated or before the
vaccines were available
so risk of infection hospital
hospitalization and death
by delta variant if a person is not
vaccinated
is eight fold
for infection
and
25 fold for hospitalization
and 24 for death
so
the vaccination
provides significant protection against
hospitalization and death and some
protection against infection
there's also been
a trial with variant vaccine so that
instead of the original gohan strain
the variant especially the delta variant
have also been tried that but alpha beta
and delta have all been tried and they
found
that
safety was there
and so was immunogenicity
we also feel that a nasal spray
vaccination
which would
uh encourage iga
type of antibodies will protect not only
against
um against hospitalization but also
against colonization and trials are
ongoing to try out the legal free
vaccine
finally it is to decide
or to understand
why some people die and others survive
this study was reported from yale which
indicated
that
persons who do not
generate neutralizing antibodies by day
14 of infection
have more chances of dying
and if by 14th day of infection you have
neutralizing antibodies then chances of
survival are high
so it was the 14th day which appeared
critical of infection if by 14th day you
have utilizing antibodies chances of
survival are high and if by 14th day
antibodies are not developed then it
might end quickly
recently
from peru they have reported that
nanobodies
have been found in llamas and
those have high ability to utilize
like sars kobe 2
and maybe they will soon come into
therapeutic use
so there's a lot of things available but
deviation from covet appropriate
behavior is currently the biggest
variant of concern and i hope that while
we strengthen
diagnostic ability
as well as our treatment facilities you
should continue to practice
over the appropriate behavior
that's all the presentation i had
thank you so much dr ratten for that
informative presentation and we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you
want to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
so it looks like we already have some
great questions coming in
our first question
in your country sir how is the vaccine
coverage is the third booster dose
already implemented
uh in india recently we celebrated one
billion
doses of vaccines
we have a population of 1.3 billion
65 percent
of that population is eligible for
vaccination at this point in time
and it appears that 20 percent has been
fully vaccinated and many more about
71.71 billion have
received at least one dose
at this moment
booster dose has not been allowed or
permitted in india
thank you so much
now our next question coming in
do you have some evidence about the
performance of trimeric s igg assay with
the delta variant
yes uh i showed you the data that i had
with our own staff members who
contacted the infection in
may
in april and may of this year they had
very high titles after they have
recovered
many of them have been vaccinated some
of them were not vaccinated
but they produced high title of
antibodies and once they have high
titles of trimeric antibodies they also
have high titles of neutralizing
antibodies so neutralizing antibodies is
a manual process by doing elisa while
climatic is an automated chemilumiscence
process which is faster and better
and
more hands-off so it is suitable for
high throughput and
high titles of antibodies were found in
those persons
who had suffered from death
thank you so much dr ratten and i want
to thank our audience for these great
questions we have one more question
coming in dr ratan
literature is reporting that there are
certain groups of amino compromised
patients for example hiv
and patients that do not just differ in
their serological response to
vaccinations from the healthy controls
would it make more sense to first
measure their serological response after
vaccination prior to giving them an
additional vaccine dose what are your
thoughts about that
uh unfortunately in our group we have
not had anybody who has hiv positive
so
i don't have any data on hiv
but on the other hand as i have
indicated that those who had infection
in 2020
and got one back one dose had high types
of antibodies so on one hand we say
that there is shortage of vaccination on
the other hand we are giving a second
dose to those who don't require it
so i think it will be judicious that
those who give history of getting
infected and then having one one
vaccination those or one dose and then
infection
should have their antibodies tested
before the second dose is given because
as kramerkar also indicated there are
more side effects if you already have
high antibodies and then you take the
second dose of the vaccination
doctor
oh go ahead
and there's also that those who are
elderly or those who have any
immunocompromised data
should get their antibodies tested
because not everybody is responding and
it is clear
that it is antibodies which are
protecting against
hospitalization and death and that is
why monoclonal antibodies are also
available for both for prevention as
well as therapy so for
personal health
those who are immunocompromised or
who are elderly should get their
antibodies tested
dr batten i want to thank you for your
presentation today would you like to
provide any closing remarks to our
audience before they go
i think i would like to repeat once
again that the virus
seems to be very smart and it is
the covid appropriate behavior
uh that means wearing the mask when in
public
keeping distance not congregating
in uh indoors and not
having too many meetings
face-to-face meetings we should continue
to do that
while we hope that the vaccine
will hold and the virus will no longer
mutate and become more immunogenic more
transmissible and
with will have immune escape mechanism
dr raj and i want to thank you again for
your time and for your research we also
want to thank lab roots and our sponsor
diashorn for underwriting today's
educational webcast and before we go i
want to thank the audience
for joining us today and for other
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration and this webcast
can be viewed on demand lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time take care everyone stay safe
bye
thank you